and today they will turn to the lefty
kwang hun kim
and he has a record of one win and five
losses
well kim knows how to pitch and it's
going to be about him putting it in the
strike zone don't nibble so much move it
up move it down change their eyes
swaying and a miss and that's how we
start play comes back to get him
the 2-2 pitch
swung on and missed and a strikeout for
kim
two in the inning diamondbacks strand a
pair and the cardinals coming up in the
home half of the first eback starter
today the right hander out of lufkin
texas it's riley smith
19 appearances five stars today is first
start since may 14. 14th
riley will rely heavily on that sinker
average velocity right around 92 93
miles an hour also throws a change up
and a hard slider he does have a
curveball but rarely uses it
that's lifted in the air out to deep
left field it's at the wall
off the top of the wall
and goldschmidt standing up at second
base missed a home run by maybe a foot
[Applause]
chomps at the first one easy fly ball
for reddick in right field
and riley smith strands the one out
double we've played one it pushed daddy
in st louis no score
[Music]
that's a thing if you watch tony in the
dugout rarely if ever smiled
but he did have a sense of humor that
was the thing about tony
there's a strikeout after the lead-off
walk the great throws of rick and killed
that famous night in denver
and yachty it's tough to get him out of
the lineup
and he serves it into right field
that'll be a base hit
second hit for st louis watch yachty
he's seen the exact same thing we do
he's seen the route and seen him change
things thought it was over his head and
that's why he rounded second
on a no two pitch a base hit off the bat
of in mundo's sosa
so at least the cardinals get the
pitcher through the lineup here
two hits in the inning runners at first
and second for the cardinals with two
outs in the home half of the second
kim with a fly ball out to left that is
over rojas
one run in
here comes another
kim drives in two
kk makes it two nothing cardinals with a
double
well you just said pitchers can't hit
but who says that kim getting a sinker
out over and drives it into left field
wait a minute wait a minute here
he could really run that's what i said
you were talking about making him drag
money he just hit a double
well i'd rather see him bunt but now i
see that let him swing away
2-2 pitch
swung on and missed and a strikeout that
is number four for kim
kk with sharp movement tailing down and
in on that slider cabrera struck out
with two on to win the first
as drooble punches it the other way
here comes rojas here's the throw
and he's in there
d-max on the board the rbi fours jubal
cabrera tommy edmond the right fielder
looked like he had a play on the plate
throw might have beat him there but
rojas snuck in
edmond coming up throwing all the way
one hopper a little bit into foul
territory
hard slide into the plate right there by
josh rojas
yeah the audi just went to tag a spot
and josh got his foot around the mid and
on to the plate before the tag was
applied nice job
infield brought in for the diamondbacks
tyler o'neal o'neill
up the middle base hit on the 1-2 pitch
tyler o'neal makes it 3-1 cardinals and
it's back to a two-run lead for st louis
o'neil protected with two strikes gets a
fastball over the heart of the plate
trying to go in to beat him in there to
jam him not able to do it tyler o'neill
capitalized on it rbi
[Music]
runner goes pitch low and a stolen base
for o'neal the ball into center field
he'll wind up at third
there you go the cardinals thinking the
same thing 2-2 count
he can go now because the pitcher
doesn't want to get to 3-2 because then
he's stealing anyway but creates havoc
they throw it away now tyler neal is
that third molina with a base hit into
right
that'll score tyler o'neal and makes it
4-1 at cardinals
yadi
his second hit these two for two 4-1 our
score
there's a
strikeout number five for kk
so lead off walk and now he's got the
next two
and the one two is lifted in the air
tyler o'neal
near the line and makes the catch
kk is through four and it's a 4-1 st
louis lead
paul goldschmidt pair of doubles today
on one and two it's another extra base
hit for paul goldsmith into right center
a run will score goldie took the wide
turn around first but he'll stop there
that'll make it five to one
and he's three for three
in my household
the braves were like the cardinals are
here yeah some good teams
ground ball carpenter
and a one two three for kk
midway through five and st louis on top
tommy edmond is over two he's flying to
left and lined out
into center field and here comes tyler
o'neil
the throw to the plate
not in time and the speed of edmond he
winds up at second it's another two out
rbi base hit for st louis and it's six
to one
one hit in the series coming into this
one but so far is three for three and
drives this deep to center le castro
runs it down he's into the wall
tim lacastro go again at carlson back to
first holy gave it a ride
in the final road trip before the
all-star break
o'neal with a drive into left center
one hopper and a ground rule double into
the bleachers
single pair of doubles for tyler o'neill
three hit dave
edmond
right side nifty play there unable to
turn two and the run will score
that'll make it seven to one
well tommy edmond knowing that there's
an rbi situation tries to shoot the ball
to right side
gets it done then beats out the play for
the rbi
not even close he walks in a run
third walk in the inning three the last
four have walked walker's home to make
it 7-2
and a big chance now for peralta
off the glove of molina that was up
there so high redick comes home and it's
7-3
pier that was supposed to be a breaking
ball never took any break whatsoever
started way out of the strike zone and
stayed way out of the strike zone by the
time yada molina reacts to it from a
knee it gets all the way to the backstop
bounced over the mound up the middle
they get one
ahmed is home and it's seven to four
chipping away here
stephen vogt who bounced into the double
play in the eighth inning last night to
end the top of the eighth in that key
spot
he'll pinch it here
popped up left side
orinato foul territory with rome he's
got it and the cardinals have a sweep